The answer lies in the numbers I just wiped out.
If A got 7/12 in total, we know that 1/12 is 20,000.
So A got 140,000, which is 7 times 20,000.
Party B got 2/12 or a 6th, which is 40,000.
Party C--a disappointing 20,000.
And party D the same as party B.
If we look at the diagram, it tell you nothing about the absolute numbers.
In fact, I can change the absolute numbers.
As long as the relative percentages stay the same, it does however tell you a lot about
the distribution of the data.
It shows you that A is the dominant party that got more than 50% of the outcome
whereas B, C, and D occupies smaller slices with a slice for C
being half the size of B or D, respectively.
Again, this is called a pie chart.
Pie charts are really, really powerful to represent things like election outcomes.
In any data set we just care about the relative outcomes
and perhaps have more than just 2 classes.